thank you very much for joining this
meeting
this is the first half in Spanish of
the studio enterprise community
so we are very happy and
excited about this opportunity and
also good as I said a few
moments ago to take advantage of the momentum and the
study platform to spread
Precisely the use of this language in
different areas in the
Spanish-speaking community,
this in particular, many thanks to
Rachel from MSI, the manager of the
Price student community, for this
space,
I am Sergio García Mora and I am not part
of the studio, I am a member of Alpha  from the
chat the club of repairing with their hands
and well the one that also originates this
space
today's idea is we are going to have two
presentations the first by daniela and
then by julieta where they are going to tell about
two different use cases applied
in totally different areas
daniela in the case of daniela is
obligated in a human resources area
within the public administration  from
the province of Corrientes and the case of
Daniela de Julieta to Radon It
is about how to apply, let's say,
Remarcan in order to be able to generate 300 reports,
more than 300 personalized reports in a
group
of psychometric studies,
which are very interesting cases
because in the case of Daniela  For example,
it is about consolidating the mass of
information, something that
many of the human resources areas normally work
with with Excel and in a very slow and
laborious way, I write, it does not call them to tell
how they solved it with the king and
with her
and with the  julieta, although being
concentrated in a study group, being
able to generate personalized reports
and be able to distribute them in a
much more agile and precise way, above all
, it seems to us that in both cases it has
many applications in different
totally different fields,
so first we are going to  have both
presentations and then you're going to have a
space to do questions and
answers anyway  eras you can
make inquiries in the chat we
also invite you to make inquiries in
an application called slide
or here rachel has just shared the
link
on this platform you can ask
questions anonymously this
presentation is being recorded and then it
appears in  the study youtube channel
so if someone doesn't
want to appear they don't want their name to
appear in the presentation they
can ask the questions in slide or and
also what is interesting is
the platform and one of the advantages it
has is that you  You can vote for
the questions that interest you the most,
so if a person has already asked something
that you would like to ask, you
can post that question and that
question will appear higher up,
so we will answer all of that at the
time of the meeting and  not later
we will put it into an article that will
appear in the blog of the
interface study network community
as well as in the rest  or of the
network communities
from the studio is also something that they
promote and encourage and that they are
committed to generating
welcoming spaces
where everyone feels welcome and
safe,
this is the essence of the code of conduct
, these unpleasantness with each
other of treating us are summarized  With respect,
in this way we can generate an
experience free of harassment for everyone
where, well, it is precisely this type of
behavior that invites more
people to join in to participate, so, well,
yes,
without anything else to say, we are going to give it the
space  to daniela to start with
her presentation
hello to all all
giving you
can see sergio the presentation and also
after
the presentation
well first of all thanks it's me
richter for this space this is good for
the opportunity to come and share a
little bit our experience and everyone
to upload my name is daniela garcía
I have a degree in labor relations
from the national university of the
nord  In all this time I was
good like everyone else trying to find
my place in the profession a little bit, let's say
and there with the pandemic I realized
that I wanted to participate in this
digital transformation so to speak
and in this search I find myself with the
RR club that  well a little bit is like
an unexpected finding because I had a
big problem at work so in
parallel a course arose from this
section on well punctually to
human resources I said 'now or never'
ivan and I'm going to
tell you a little about this experience
and  Well, also,
as I was saying, I work in the Ministry
of Finance in the province of
Corrientes and I am also an extra master's degree and
now a collaborator with the Raids Club.
big data forced me to work
with him a little now I am going to tell you why,
as I was saying, he worked in the ministry
of finance that concentrates the liquidity  payment
of salaries from all the ministries
we are talking about more than 50,000
agents of which exactly
half of them without a little less
are in the ministry of education which
is the one that brought me here
in us we concentrate
as I told you all the liquidation
therefore we would have to cross-check
our database sources with those
of the other ministries and we would like to
obtain good data analyzed
information to make decisions
let's say this this is super heavy it is
super heavy we ask the
systems area for example in this
case
punctually the  information from a
ministry and even so it is
difficult for us to work with it and this
led us as a consequence that the
management reports are out of
date because we had to do so much,
perhaps it took us a month and a half or
two, it is going to be something and for example we had
information on  June we finished July
in August and that is the information we
had for when the decision maker  he could
access that information and that
was causing us some problems
and we were sincerely raffling with
excel in one way or another but
later it became impossible
it became impossible because as he
said some changes were made in the
liquidation process on
time in the ministry of
education
like the initial one who concentrated a large
number of not only agents
but these people have various positions
for example you will
remember the math teacher
it is not that she only works in the
secondary school that one goes to but that she works
in five schools and you can get up to seven
to have this then it is this
type of complexity I don't know I'm going to
investigate
friend my colleague María Vélez González
what would be the alternatives for
Excel so that is our problem of
him serving it we are going to look for something that will
help us
so good  what was the first idea
that stopped
well it was 16 megabytes in a single excel my
computer did not
work  reacted to this request, let's say,
I charged it, and if I added a
filter directly, it would not continue,
so
in this context, in principle, they had asked us for
the cost of salaries by
current department, no province in Argentina,
which has more or less 25
departments, and well, for  Of course, these
departments have locations,
we decided with the computer that
it was the best, I was even at home
to tell them, we did not even use
the work computer, we decided to
divide it into 35 files, something that we
can manipulate,
and well, the truth is that I never made friends
with  in excel
we use filters and variants of cutting
otherwise I don't remember what was done but it
was a monstrosity of mixtures
of excel formulas that in short
was copy paste copy paste and then
do a sum it was totally indecision
well we got around this somehow
way the problem was when they told us to
update the previous one and I want to
know the cost of  Each school
seemed to me not to be impossible, that is,
we were directly there, well,
we will learn, we said, let's see what
the power day is about, I don't know, well, in
this context, the course for
human resources came up
and the solution basically,
so good in all this mess that they
I commented that there are 4,000 48,500 positions at
five educational levels, it would be at the
initial level, primary, private, secondary, and I
advise that if the substitutes
for 2,000 schools, 50 types of positions, it
can be a teacher of the teacher, a teacher
of the first of the second, the
presenter, the
director of the first of the second, the  area
that it has, that is, it was really an excel
of columns up to z more or less and
well and of rows the number of posts
after 26 localities and we
could not cross all this and finish
this year practically when they
were housing updated information
so well not so well basically reaction comes in
and then
once we found the network
happily we found out  that they have
packages, that is, one says programming nr
and that's why we got a little scared,
we came from another background, my
partner has a degree in
administration,
so we weren't very
familiar with this type of
work, when feeding the course and learning about
the packages,
the march began  here we have good in
this case we basically use nine packages
and once we open it the
file is ready to start working
I am going to tell you more or less a
little about what are the packages that
we use this well
in principle the rip package that we
use for  read the excel files
those principles
basically the systems out there
had the
predisposition to cut the files
up to a certain point but they weren't
totally raw and they didn't pass them in
excel well I could also give the
past few months
later
we used funk modeling to do
exploratory analysis  of data that
helped us to measure the volume of
work with not being  capable of 34
madryn functions we already had an idea of the avera
e of the median of the deviation in qu
st
ons that sincerely in excel you g
t a lot of functions in fan madri
and you know where you stand and you c
n go to bazaars or program what
n  pando in definition
then we use villager for
data manipulation I say
cordovil because the truth is that the
functions that have to select filter
order mutate well and add there would be
the functions that have to do with
statistics are the ones that we are
familiar with in reality
quietly  and they help us to carry out
the work in the way one would
think because ultimately, for
example, if I want to
know about the teachers who are in
primary school,
I can only select that so that
the object is smaller, then I can
make a filter  maybe you want to
choose the preceptors just or maybe
categorize between teachers and non-teachers
and say in the  code which ones are
teachers and which ones are teachers, that is,
administrative,
then we can order this we can
perform calculations between two columns or
in order and overcome
the old reliable one, let's say that it helps us
to perform any calculation, which
is ultimately what we want to make
decisions
immediately  We have the package to
categorize the data, which is the forcat
, it helped us a lot because, in fact,
as he gave the diversity between positions
between how the educational levels are
, they forced us to have an
idea so that the people who needed to
see the report were the minister
education and I also have even the
governor to
have an idea of which is the majority of wh
ch represents the majority of let's
say one tries to solve all the p
oblems but ultimately we st
rt with those that have the most impact or because of what
as the most quantity that will depend on strat
gy not  this did not
ultimately serve to convert what is
up there into what is  would go down there
automatically, this would show us
which would be the variable that has the most
frequency and so on we can
group, for example, in others the 6%
later, in terms of data visualization,
we use limp both to
create and automate the graphs and
carl  extra to make such rows this one
because this is good I
find in terms of the elaboration of
the graphs that it is something that we
all do also as I say
in this case the graphs can be automated
not only with the type of
graphs that one intends to show but
also with  colors with formats this
really is to copy and paste and change the
object and there you can use the same
the same graphic for everything you
need and well they fit to make
nice tables it's out there a
little rustic in terms of the way of
show things but for that there are
the packages that help us make it more
beautiful also in short what is the
visualization that a part imports
Before data analysis, it should be
user-friendly, intuitive, storytelling,
states or the tools that we
use, now
we carry out automation,
that's what we shouldn't talk about, and then, in
principle, this part of the
good script allows you to place the author by means of the
title.  the date and here with these
40 podiums that go what we do is
change the theme of the report well choose
the color and
determine if we want it to be seen or not
there is code this will perform some
action to hide it and well
basically that's good even  In order to
allow the download of the code,
you can also do all these are
configurations that are defined at the
beginning of the highlighting and then
well, now I am going to show you in an
example
the report
that you see here once all this is defined,
now I  I would love to show you how
it is generated but apparently as
downloading the problem on another computer it does
not allow me but it is only with  this
button only with the thousand button and
the report is already generated is not complicated
at all and
in what you see below for example it is in
the instructions that I am giving
to rd if I want it to be displayed or not or
as follows here for example  I was
commenting on the introduction, then we
present a second approach, which
is ultimately what
the person who is receiving
the report needs to know is that they need to interpret
those graphs, those tables that we
show them
with this code, what I do is
generate the spaces so that  there are
fewer more spaced and here in more what
you see around there in another color when you return
would be the codes themselves in
this case for a matter of good
practices and there are also two of us left and just in
case maybe we leave this and
another takes it up  person
we make the determination to use
comments to have a notion of what
we are doing for example open
packages
cut the data do passing  to a
factor to build categories count
total posts and so on
using all the packages
that I mentioned
and
then through the button and what is done is to
finalize the amount of the report it would be and
that it is directly eligible for the
user this that would be
I fly backwards,
well, regarding this that cost us, it
was a little difficult at the beginning and
one ends up being a better known bad guy,
this one does not want to go back to excel,
but well, once we begin to see
that this made sense, we continue, we
continue until the first of several
reports that we had to carry out of
this magnitude later
may be the mornings we say here in
Argentina to something like you have to know how to
treat it, let's say for example in
loading packages there you have to
reload it there if in this case for
example that I  I moved machines and it's hard for me to
open the file, these are things that
can be solved, let's say downloading
loading things that Julián doesn't know  and they are
solving but the first ones as one
is not used to it, we do not point later
that it may be that we had to learn to
use repositories it is not as well drive
of voice your vice lowers but in short
there are tutorials for everyone so that way
you can work collaboratively and
well  and you also have
programming options ultimately because that's
how you upload the codes
and it's practical I think it's the same
way on second thought it's not
something that costs so much either because I understand
that any tool you
use is ultimately a matter of
practice  that is not in the automation of
reports because we did this report
once but for a little more month but
not quite the same and in a matter of
changing the rate that is exactly the
same and automatically it will be seen
of course if we use marlowe there will be
to review the data again to
make the pertinent comments of an
analyst but what is data analysis
s itself is already done
another thing is that these codes are
highly recyclable we use them later
to make other types of reports a
little more complex with more
databases among which they were not unified
later the syntax is simple it
needs to allow other types
of the code to learn  programming language
there are many ways to do the same thing
we also learned in the er club there are
many ways to write many ways
to do it is a matter of searching the
community that is very friendly and open
just how could something
like that be done that's good  that would be two for my
part I thank you for good from
me and my partner that he can not
attend but to any question he
gave
me an excellent exam in a rain of
reactions
in the chat for
Daniela's presentation remember what you can do
the queries on slide or something like that later
when julieta's presentation ends
we can go over all
the questions
[Music]
and she
asks them  mos at the end
well
they give you a question about their offspring and
then you can share the code
if the code if there is where we
can share it sex
in their hands forged by rijkaard
well
well then she
had open the presentation and julieta
well now to present her case of
use of er mark down reports
in research in a
psychometric research group so julieta
very well thank you very much it
is shared
very well
well first of all thank you for
inviting us I am going to tell you a little about what
we do in the accounts well I am
julieta and just like that  let me tell you
about how we generate technical reports
without committing psychometrics with the
semarnat
I am a psychologist and I work in a
research team when on light
I have a degree in psychology I studied at
one of the company's universities
I am a researcher at the
3rd international skip this
reconstruction
we are a group of researchers for the
discount a little more than it is the
work  garlic as I express char in the
galicia bank and I really like this subject
of programming and data analysis
the icbc is a group that creates a
pandemic we are the ones here in the
photo and we have worked for
two years now  we are working with are
groups of color
, psychology students,
business marketing graduates, and
others who come together to investigate the
research we do is
basically on behavior with a mission,
personality,
and we are also quite interested in the subject
of education. We thought that
education in the  context of kobe and others
I am going to do something very interesting
what we did was to do
psychometric techniques
through video calls we did tests with
different people that is what is
called psychometric tests we have
a person who answers and for them to
answer a series  of tests these tests
basically return
an excel database and what we have to do
is analyze what  what it gives us in
those tests are raw numbers that don't
mean anything but we have to give them
meaning we have to make those
numbers have
a reason why not
then we did all that
data collection we had the
databases and apart  Hence, something that
seemed important to us, in addition to taking everything
in you, was to be able to give back to each
person who took the time, which was
around two hours, between two and three
hours per video call with us,
doing a lot of tests, to be able to
give them back in some way.  a
retribution for that time and that
predisposition
therefore we took a series of the
tests that we had taken them and we
wanted to give them that evolution the issue is
that we had to make more than 300
personalized returns where we also had
a large amount of data there were
many  numbers a lot of data
in an excel sheet we had very little
time because we also promised them
this return
immediately  people asked us if
we could send them what was the
evolution of the three that
had taken so much time and
effort we
need it to be a
professional production alone as psychologists
wanting to contribute to all this
psychological research and others
and with our icr that sport
we wanted to show a certain
professionalism in the production in what
we told them to select the
people, therefore from
the very beginning we thought that
exhale could not be an option we
could not send each participant an
ecce we
also need to include graphics
now I am going  to show, but there is a
part where we have a series, it is a
graph, they make us comparisons on
different subscales of a scale that
we take
and we need to be able to compare it, so we
need a graph for each person
and we need it to be simple,
easy to read, although  everything that is
research is quite complex and
can be difficult to understand  tend
difficult to read that is easy to read
at that time well he proposed to do it
with an excel but for a matter of time
of effort because our team is
made up of us who get
together on Sunday mornings to work
with the love that we have in him  the
investigation, but well, we didn't
have the time, nor could we
take so much time and
make so much effort to generate the
reports. At that time, I had already completed
the record-breaking course
here with Sergio and the Sun, just with that
little bit that I had learned, let's say with
that introduction to what we still
needed to learn a lot and it
occurred to me that we could do a lot
so I proposed to the team to be able to
use it for the first time because the
truth is that there are not many
research teams that have any
approach to what is programming or
the deepest and most complex data analysis
so I proposed to do it and well it was a
challenge to be
able to put all this together so that it came out  n
the channels I'm going to show you
so well we chose to use branches
for a few which was the best
tool to generate this type of
return
the first thing I thought was what we
had to do it was not what we
needed to put in that report so
we put together one  I think it is more or less
than what it should have had, we had what
we are going to have, we had the results of
the working memory profile, which is
a test called Euskal, the
spatial vision processing profile, which is
a test called es  Spanish and the
results of the
learning and self-regulation strategies to each
of these we needed to put a
description an introduction
so that the person who
was reading it understood what it was
about from that had the
results of the same participant and  a
conditional answer if I get between
so many and such a number that an
answer appears without giving between all of it and it is
at the other number that another appears
response and others in each of these 3
and in this last one of
self-regulation learning strategies
we also needed this graph where
we had we can compare and we
also need a line that tells us what
the cut-off point is
and a result and a recommendation
we also wanted to add  to this
report the logo of the reset list the
name of the investigation the
thanks to the person who
participated and the social networks so that they
were born and can give me to join
new
investigations all this remains what we wanted to
put the only one
I bring you here  you can scan the code on the qr code
if you want with your cell phone, but by
setting up the bar j, it takes right
there and there is a null version and
organization 2 of how we went and they will have
the destinations in 1x what was the code
for what are you going to  stay the best so that the
best goes well and arriving in another
way
and well, however the qr code will
appear in all the others
[Music]
perfect screens I'm going to show you a little bit of
what I wrote and what
actually appears on the page you will
see everything in full even if you put the
button that says code it is where you can see
the written code of the code that  receives
for what appears on the screen
however I try to put it together
so well
in this same way also not this
first part where I give it a name
and I put an author but in reality
what I am going to replace it with is  for an
image that is this one that you see here
this image I generated it with canvas the
truth is that it was not a great effort to be
able to add a bed put our
logo a name that is presentable and
that is striking no then I
can upload it to  this first part and that
it is not just text so that it is
more striking you can do it this way
simply by adding this portion of
code at the end and well in the same
way to the side why to the
results if you have the memory  at
work you can click and so on this
that showed my partner rachel
what the top-flop is if you can
download the code in this case we
have put it to download
the color theme and so on and we have
asked it to come out  with html we had seen
the option of downloading it as a pdf
but long it lost a lot of sense of
being to do it let's say rolling up our sleeves
gave it another meaning another way of
viewing another tour of the
page that didn't offer us any in
any other way
so we did it  in this way the
following
in this part
the first part what we needed
was the results of the participant and
here it says one and I the truth is that the
campus of the participant 105 was made
only with this that was the idea not to be
able only in one place in one  line
of code to be able to change the number and
automatically bring us the
participant of those more than 300 because
the reality is that we sent 300
expected, they were many more
then  It is me in this way only by
changing the number there and it will bring the
result of the participant that I
would like and if it is going to reflect here
everything that is
research in psychology, what we
assure the participant is that we are going
to use their data from their information
the results to the statistical
research mode and that the data will not
be violated, no one will have access
, therefore, we gave each participant
a number, so we have to
treat it as a participant number and
not with a name and surname, which is  other
important things also that
we had to fulfill in this case both
what you are seeing here and in
arrested are all data the
fictitious pixies are
random of random numbers
but we were left with a very good example of
how they really came out
so well in this way what  I
worked with
signs and bad memories, there were three
excel, that is, three databases for a
topic about the time it took for the information to
arrive  ormation if they are three
different times, however in version 2 it is
directly a single file with all the
information, that is why as soon as
they read the code, it only
loads several times, I asked you to
take it from different more of this database
and then what I told you before I
needed to be able to load the database
and ask a conditional in this case it
is the gateway only in cases in
which taking spam would give from such a number to
such a number that has a type of
response if it has  another number that gives
other answers and so it is this part
that is here
after that what I did was
generally good that I took the idea
of the subject and if it receives from here I what I am do
ng from the resul
s table of that database  data to ask
you to remind you to go specifically
to a data to a response to a number
and turn it into a response and
what I told them to have the
raw number and change it even to that number
has a meaning  do
and then down here what I always ask him
to bring me the number and that
he bring me the result in number
and the result of the interpretation is
not a result then later down here
what I do is ask him through
this part that is here that is as
if it were a tick for one side that
is and I call it there there are videos under
subject that is this that is here for
example then I tell the result
the participant number here brings me the
number of  participant who is
looking for it
here and down here it is the same I am asking you to
bring me the interpreted result let's say
the result of working memory
that generates it here
in this way is how I am doing it
in all the others that I feel is here for
example  how it looks is how it is he says he
wants it is the participant who is the
memory of the work what are the
results of this person and what is the
interpretation of the result that he gave
to that person why it does not work for me
dec  go to the person he gave you 25 if you don't
tell him it's high it's low it can be improved it
's within the average that's the idea
here the same thing basically what I did
in this part is the same load a
database also with the case
well  I asked for
different answers and interpretations
according to the number I was taking and
in the same way I asked him here to
look for me, for example, result 2 and
then this is the one here,
result 2 the interpretation y
so this is how  it looks like this
the name of the test we took what it
means and below what the result is
for example here it says your ability to
maintain and manipulate data from
visuospatial equipment is very high you are
above 75 percent compared to US
students congratulations this
this is  What we want to get at is
not the idea in research in
psychology, this type of report is to
tell them that it is not quite normal, but rather to
compare, to give a range
of reference to understand  er as one
is fine for example the processing is
in this part in the
learning strategies profile here is
the graph that I told you where
we had to have at 50 which is the
cut-off point is if it is above it
would be
within  expected or above what was
expected and below could do something
to work so all those who
gave low it seemed to us that as
psychologists we had to be able to say
we can be able to give a recommendation but
as the majority of our
participants were students if it gave
under the regulation of effort
let's suppose  to be able to tell the person
how to improve this part to be
able to study better since it deals with
learning strategies, so in
this part we also load the
database and ask that we be able to attach all
these 6 subscales within
message strategies, the subscales
and  with sisi plot what we did was
load the entire order and even make the
line in the middle for
the response  this is the data that appeared in
that database that responded to the test
that he answered
the person who answered the test for us
so in this way it was also
simply to explain what it is about and
load in the image for this it follows
we also had to be able to explain  As
we said before, the subject of the subscale
as interests, expectations of success,
sanction before the exams, the
percentage given because in the previous one we are
graphing it, so the percentage was important
and here the description, for
example, of what the interest is
and below what we established  it was that if it
was below what was expected to be able to
give this recommendation and if not to
congratulate the person because they were doing
well,
so here in the same way and always
repeating the truth is that it has this
ease of being able to recycle by
going back to drinking and  when you understand it
is an idea everything else comes out much
easier much faster then here I
had the same thing well this is much more tree
what the cuts to show but
here for example I am asking
you to cut the results for me row 1
row 2 row 3 and each meaning
and something that means for example I
asked you to cut me from the database
this is  which is called interest, so
here I am, where I am writing
what I want to appear on
the screen, I ask you to replace it, I generate it
as a template so that this
database replaces more and also
replaces me, it brings me the information of the
percentage and that he understands if the
percentage is below or
above what was expected, so we give recommendations or
congratulate
and now reaching the end in this last
part where we also had to
thank you for the participation because I already
told you it was between 2 and 3 hours  each
person each volunteer gave us to be
able to do this research and that the
desire that self-managed teams
like ours
are this style we need people
who want  It was to participate
that they give us their time and
effort
and we can give this type of
evolutions that are not important
in this part, well, we needed to put
this well, I also generated it with
shrimp and the truth was that it was beautiful, it
was very nice to see in  the page
and below we are with the networks
so what I was able to bring was the
tiny image of essential linkedin facebook
which is where we upload
our scientific research and
the linkedin facebook link and others
so that they can follow us
later also to grace here  you can't see
the source code here is the git hub
where you can go to download that code
there were many people many volunteers who
participated who are
from the psychology research area and when
doing this it measures that other groups
can also replicate it  because at the end of the
day,
the love of science and research
is that more people can access
this in a fast, simple, agile way.
Igable that they can learn it as
quickly as the premise
with such basic knowledge and that
tomorrow we can do it in many
research groups and we can have
more data which means
more general results that can be generalized and that
reach the population better,
so good  When we finished, the
results
we obtained with this code were
completely different from those we
said when we thought where
we said we do it in excel, which was not
only a possibility and it was simple,
the truth is that the sole was inside the
first time I  they sat down to write
a code
and the truth is that it had its complexity
but later it became simple easy what
we said recently by searching google
asking in the community there is always
someone who tells you I have five minutes
I give you a hand and I help you and we get it out
and  It came out in a very professional way. The
truth is that all the people who
wear
it saw it as super professional, simple from the start.
tender
and even
[Music]
we sent it in html format
so we had to open it yes or yes as
chrome internet explorer and we thought it
was going to be there could be some problem in
everyone who received it and
nevertheless there was no
problem because it was  equal to an
internet page
so this was from the team it
was also received with great joy
that from now on we have these
tools available that we can
continue creating
so this is all I leave you my
linkedin it is in the mail in case you
want me  make a query and right
now I share the bit code
many times
good very good excellent excellent very
interesting the case you can imagine
how using this always for example with
climate surveys to criticize them is
also one of the problems we have
working from  human resources is that
since we take a long time to deliver the
results there is no minor end doing
things like this
well let's com  start with
the questions
and answers and there is one that applies
to both of them,
how they share information, for
example
this advantage of excel that you can have
as
in a shared environment and everyone
accesses that then daniela
microphone and how they share the
report the reports afterwards
what a
good thing precisely the first time we
use this report for example that you have
seen
precambrian mind and we go up in the
drive and there we update because we didn't
know but then well
as
developers of all programming languages normally do we us
a repository on githu
it was good precisely in one of the
sections of the deere club for
human resources that
were good they were open sessions
what was taught to use these
repositories punctually leave them not
needed there are other types
there are others
for example
excel
good in this step by  example
just download the packages so
you can see  and I have the file as
with the original data to tell you
but that is when we give it to my
boss which is the one he projects in
a meeting with the governor for example what
you do with the right click
opens it in a browser and  it automatically
comes out and anyone can open it, that is,
we all have a browser on the
computer so that would be
basically obviously to turn it off
governor goes directly without codes and
nothing graphic text graphic text and nothing
else let's say now if I for
example want to share it with someone  person
who wants to work if he would use the now or
we use the repository to give the times
7 I don't know if that answers the query
and then about sharing the
information or bring a text that
arose in particular from things with the
destroyed groups was if that information
it remained in a cloud
published for example in the red bulls
as they did to protect the
confidentiality of each
of each participant of each  voluntary
yes in that case actually as the
databases are in the computer and
they are not uploaded to any cloud that is everything
that is what I uploaded finally it was
all with the
invented database that is that they are danny they are a
lie
and among us we share the
real data that never comes out that is always
confidential and even if they are
converted to their numbers, that is, if
there are real cases but in reality they are
converted to numbers and not with a name and
surname that is not in any way due to
our coincidence  ity that we
provide as psychologists in no
way can not be accessed on the one hand it
never talks about our pc if our
databases of researchers
that is confidential readings but
everything that this has uploaded and everything that
is loaded hide my is simply
to show this template let's say so
that people can reply
well you told me that it took between 1 and
2 months to make the reports before
now in four  They are taking a long time
to see what it would take once
the system wants to pass us on because that
also delayed us, of
course, the dependency for the
system area does not finish disappearing, but
imagine if I asked them what
the excel is missing, we actually asked for it, no
I want to lie, we ask you, it works for us
a little and then, well, we become
independent, this nothing will take five
minutes, which is basically to
update the file, to tell you,
we work by the month, so
that is, I don't know about December, it will say
January, January 22, we change from Excel and
nothing else  We are now reprinting it,
obviously, as I say, what is going
to change again, biological, which is what
an analyst does, which is to see, for example, in
relation to the previous month, this has
had an increase in analysis, but
the report itself
and for my note
that is, we went from a 12-month period to 5
minutes
and zero stress, of
course, of course,
well, to each of the questions that
came to julieta in slide or do you have to
v  er says in the one that pedro did in the
case of psychometrics how the results
are different for each user
how they made it so that a user
prefers his own result but not that
of the others
[Music] let's
see if I understood correctly we have
results  of each person, that is, each
person responds and has given a gross number,
let's say 5 and we have that number to be
able to transform it, we have to compare
it or have them to which we can compare
as in the one I read that it said it is
within the estimated range or above
of which 95% which in 95% of the
is also stand out in this test for
example
and
today we have scales of cut-off points all
that psychometrics all statistical Friday
but it tells us where we
stand if below above
within the  average then we have
data on each person as unemployed with
something based on some other data that has
already been studied and this study with
a large population then we
we say well where that person is
located that with this population that has already
been studied I already tell you this this issue
of cut-off point scales and others that
we use and that depends on each test
each test comes with its way of evaluating
so if we give
this  back how each person is
located according to
other people depends on what they have
cards is how we locate it that would be the
idea they
passed depending on the result in the
sample the document will be personalized
take them out
if it is compared with that
with what we have with  that nap in the
meantime is located here if it is
among the other numbers it goes in another place
each one has their answer
[Music]
another question is the income you can
open the microphone and expand a little
on this so you can customize the
templates when generating  the information
good afternoon and good is this
question two templates to address
that many
government institutions of some of several
private require  they want and demand that certain patterns be
followed in the presentation
of two of them reports so they have
to be so cheeky such a color tag
file has to be in such a way that it
has to have the institutional band
and streets cuba here is institution power
here in  name and when you want things like
that of that type that
is a requirement of their own their
own then I wanted to know
everything you can take this
good product the information they generate that I
saw that to add peace
you cannot start one to
through some triples of pere but with one
how to accommodate those templates if
suddenly you can take those
simple ones in a personalized way
ensuring
the institutional requirements
I have some institutions that happens in a
convenient way then if both
countries pass but here it happens a lot it is a
bureaucratic issue  but it is necessary
in my case punctually the color
green is the color of the ruling party yes or
if it has to be  ar this out there the
fonts and those questions are
quite quite free however if
I wanted to make a template and of
course that can be done
julia and she showed for example in the case
of putting the logos to access
social networks that is in  my case colo
colo lo lópez hugo let's say the provincial coat of arms
when it is always
green which is specific the typography
for personal reasons this good
we choose the legible ones let's say obviously
the size of the title of the subtitle all
that can be determined by programming this
in principle it seems a little
complicated to say, well, I have to
remember how to do it, for example, how to
do it in bold or normal italics,
I remember it was in two asterisks on one
side and two on the other
like this, and to want to
correct this tip, that type of question
is what one  it is learning, that is, if,
for example, the good douglas r mar
ground and formats that are going to appear
as in the codes can make it  to
positive press bold the size the
space between the blocks of
information and how to place, for example,
the images and themes as I told you
colors and other things and it remains the same
beyond and you have the same
stake forever so I will  I would solve if
there is a problem
later as more complex forms the
things of those
two or three lines
also later it can also be created
as a css file that gives it all
the style such as with a
specific background with the specific background
that you want
In addition, this one
to generate the most personalized
possible and there are always packages that there are
also like that extend the range
of
the range of formats and destinations for
manual documents and that also
another question that is also in the fly
regarding well also of  We don't know if this can
be generated in google
docs or google is live,
and if it can also be done if it has a
view that tells you
how you want to save that information  rmation
when
google docs and nothing one can be an
excel what you can download in excel
pdf
html
[Music]
that many times we are
to collect information from there and
you can also write
this
but then there are other countries like for
example sharing there is
[Music]
that the cars generate for you also as
a whole presentation
within the environment of r
so you don't have to leave
er to finish with the final product
if you want to be able to work all the
data up to the communication
and
Well, another question from Gustavo is
[Música]
regarding the ability of
Latin American governments to scale up this
type of solutions, barriers and
opportunities,
well, honestly, the main
barriers are precisely the
diversity in public organizations and
that each one organizes its information
as it is  It seems to you that this is the truth,
each one has their own way of organizing
information, so you have to look for how
a primary code, so to speak, to be
able to cross-reference information, at least
in Corrientes, which is honestly one of the
poorest provinces in Argentina,
perhaps we do not have
unified databases, which leads us, for example,
to
request information from the Ministry of
Education,
which  they return us a month later
and then it's like everything goes
much slower we don't have access to what
I consider a barrier that is not
open either and that to make it
open we would also have to, as I said,
try to be
able to unify the information
through  a code that allows you to cross-reference those
data you are seeing that today
there is what is called an open government
in Argentina but at least in this
part of the country it is a bit a bit a
bit complicated that
implementation to be honest the
work has been difficult
joint work with other
ministries is very difficult
ours that we have the entire
database is a matter of  and to bother the
'system every day
fabri who like pasta frola 12
well and it
worked but well after that you can't
this is the limitation
but there it
is in our network of contacts there are just
as many people working in the public sphere
and using  of the network, in
fact, they are also taking it, they are
promoting it quite a lot, for example, the INDEC,
which is like ours, is the main
statistical agency in
Argentina and so now citizens are also doing it
in other departments and
coordination is very difficult for us,
but not
another  topic that
will be left for a next meeting
then
and
well then good and julieta has already
shared in the chat the
link to the repository of
[Applause]
the report that they have as a sample
when when the team
uploads
the recordings to youtube we will
have it included there  in any case, because
like so many juli and danny
mentioned arestrup de r óscar we also give
them access to the
cl repository  ub with all the presentations of
all the meetings that we did with
all the scripts of all the topics that we
developed that are well explained
prior to the voice test this one
stops just over there the profiles
like ours that we come from
social sciences where
all  the programming part is not pink,
it is not part of our DNA,
so there it is that access to
all the scripts that we generate puts the
meetings and also to the
wild drive folder with all the presentations
and access to the recordings so that they
can  see when they want and good with
this
that later in any case we will
answer them in the post by
esteban martín in the blog of
studied interpreters so good with this we
end today's meeting
thank you very much to all the people
who joined from
various continents of  several countries
we are very happy with the
call that we had many
thanks to daniela and julieta also for
their predisposition  Despite the
fears of the
sea, they put on
this first meeting of re-studying
enterprise in Spanish, the man is considered an
excellent edition, so
thank you very much and in
return thank you very much to 'rachel decides
for all of us to give us this space to
work with you
very many  thank you thank you all